Think about how much of our job at YC
has been decoding VC speak into English.
>> Yes.
>> Any words that aren't yes is a no, but
like with all this like extra accutrants
on the edges. If you get an email and
it's like lots of words in it, that's a
no.
>> Yes.
[Music]
Hello, this is Dalton plus Michael and
today we're going to talk about Standard
Capital, the new fund by Dalton and PB.
As a kind of 30 second preview, why
don't you tell us a little bit about um
how you decided to start this fund and
why is it different? I think to start
with um as you know I give a lot of
advice over the years as a YC partner on
pivots.
>> Yes.
>> And one of the things I I try to do when
giving someone advice about a pivot is I
try to imagine of all ideas this person
can work in the world where do they have
the most unfair advantages? Where do
they have the best network? Like I
believe that every person has like a
perfect idea for them
>> and that my job is to try to pull out of
any founder what their ideal idea is. I
have stolen that line
>> maybe a hundred times.
>> Yeah, maybe maybe a hundred times.
>> It's helpful especially in the sea of
well I could do anything.
>> Yeah, there's there's too many choices.
Too many choices.
>> But if you think about it this way,
everyone has one really good idea. And
so,
>> by the way, I love that too because it's
kind of like in a really hard
competition, you want to play games
you're good at.
>> Yes.
>> And like the world is a really hard
competition.
It's like Yeah.
Okay.
>> And so, so this is an idea that I
crafted very specifically for this
founding team, which is PB, myself, and
Brian Berg. Yes. And kind of the idea is
to take a lot of what makes YC work at
the seed stage and apply it to the
series A.
>> Um, the way I like to explain this is 20
years ago, I raised a seed round. Yep.
>> And when I raised a seed round,
>> I had to get a lead investor.
>> Yep.
>> I had to get a priced round term sheet.
Y I had to sell 25% of my company. Yep.
I had to give up a board seat and it
took seven months
>> for a seed round.
>> For a seed round. And Michael, let me be
honest.
>> It was a miracle. Like I'm I'm I'm so
thankful. No, I mean I really mean this.
Yeah.
>> Like when I think back I'm like how did
I get that done?
>> Like I think I was just lucky or it was
it was so hard.
>> Yes. When you were doing it coming out
of the 01
>> Yeah.
>> craziness. Yeah.
>> It was a it was really hard and it was a
it was basically a miracle that I got it
done. Yep. And so when you compare that
to today where there's YC anyone there
the YC invented the safe. Yes.
>> Um there's this really vibrant ecosystem
of angel investors that are used to
taking risks on on younger founders on
technical founders. Like it's like
totally different. And so a lot of my
experience of raising a seed round not
applicable not relevant in any way to
founders. Conversely I also raised a
series 8 20 years ago
>> and it was like I had to get warm
interest to people. I put them in my
CRM. I had to go on coffee dates to get
to know people and go through this
complic.
>> Oh, I love you know me. I love
coffee with random investors.
>> Yeah. That's like love that stuff.
>> Fill my calendar.
>> And and then the the crazy thing about
the process that I remember and I'm sure
this still stings you.
>> Yeah.
>> Is where you would spend all this time
with people over weeks or months and
they would like want to go out to dinner
and be your best friend and talk about
how great you were. Yeah. And then like,
"Oh, you know, we're definitely coming
in." And then they would like pass at
the very end,
>> often silently.
>> They would ghost you.
>> Yes.
>> Um or they would be Yeah. They would be
like, "Oh, this is just a preuncter.
Like, we're definitely in." And then you
would get like the very weird pass at
the end after literally months of time
and effort.
>> Yes.
>> And it was crushing
and it was a huge time waste. And I felt
horrible because I wasn't working on my
startup when I was doing these
fundraisers. I was instead said
fundraising.
>> Well, and to that point, I was told like
this was an important part of being a
founder, but I'd always found it a
little confusing.
>> Well, you weren't adding any value.
>> Yeah, my company was Yeah, my company
was getting worse.
>> It's like, you know,
>> here's a side quest and you need money,
but like I feel like that was a bit of a
lie. Like, oh, this side quest is going
to help you with your gun. It's like,
>> yeah,
>> no, it's going to get me money. Part of
why I liked YC is PG was the only person
who was honest about this in his blog
post which is like yeah fundraising is a
waste of time don't do it like to do it
as do it in as short of amount of time
as possible. This is like core in the YC
bible is this stuff. Um anyway so to
complete the thought Michael that was
all what I remember. Guess what?
>> It's the same now. Like all of the
advice, all of my experience as a
founder raising an A is precisely what I
still hear as a YC group partner on what
it's like to raise an A, which is like,
yes,
>> oh, you get this inbound from people and
they act like they're they're really
interested, but then you get into these
really long complicated processes and
most of the time
>> it's a lot of very complicated, flowery
words, which mean no.
>> Yes.
>> Think about how much of our job at YC
has been decoding VC speak into English.
>> Yes. And and again, I tell the
>> it's always yes and no.
>> Yes. That's to tell the audience if it's
not any words that aren't yes is a no,
but like with all this like extra
accutrants on the edges. Okay. Like if
there's lots of word if you get an email
and it's like lots of words in it,
that's a no.
>> Yes.
>> It's so funny cuz it's like a plate full
of garnishes. Yes.
>> And just like a no in the middle of it.
There's just a no in the plate.
But they serve me this inc. Why would
they spend so much time? They must be
really interested.
>> Like no, I don't. That's just a no.
That's just a regular no.
>> So yeah. So the process is still
awkwardly slash maybe needlessly
painful.
>> Look, if we want to humanize the
investors on the other side of the
table, this is just how it's always been
done. So I would I would I would argue
it's I don't think they're evil.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But I'm use the word
awkward. It's the process that has been
the process since the 1980s. And so when
you know Steve Jobs was raising money
for Apple computer, this is the same
process
>> that he used in the 1980s. Um well let's
and like let's absolve them. VCs have to
go to other investors to raise money.
>> Precisely.
>> And so needless to say it's a little bit
easier especially if you don't have a
stellar track record to just say I'm
doing it like almost you want to do
something different. That's like the
worst thing you could do. Yeah. Um
>> especially in an asset class that seems
like it's working and blah blah blah
blah. Yeah.
>> And so that's the context which is look
we saw what made YC work. Uh PB was was
at the second demo day as an angel
investor.
>> We should probably introduce PB a little
bit more.
>> You should say who PB is.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So uh PB Paul Buhight. Um, I
often tell founders that Paul Buhight
gave both of my startups the single most
important pieces of advice, which is
crazy because it was like, you know, it
was like infinite value creating the
first time and then like I still
remember the second time being like,
wait, I think he might have just did it
again.
>> Like what are you like what is
happening?
>> He just drops truth truths on you,
Michael. Just dropping a truth bomb.
>> Bang. So, um, Paul was a very early
employee of of Google.
>> 23. He was number 23.
>> 23. Um, he was an angel investor in a
lot of companies, uh, Twitch and Social
Cam included.
>> I always respected his his style. He he,
you know, he's not going to hold your
hand and give you like eight hugs and be
like, "Oh, how do you feel today about
the experience of a startup?" He's not
going to do that. But like when you give
him a problem, there's like an 85%
chance he will give you a better
solution than you're going to come up
with. And like he's been doing it for
like 20 years. Like
>> Yeah. I mean, it's one of those things
when you meet someone that's really
smart, you can just tell that they're
just offering with more horsepower. Like
whatever's going on.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> He's he's got a lot of horsepower up
there. And so if you can kind of direct
them the right way, you're going to get
a you're going to get a nugget. And like
you know, it turns out companies don't
need like a hundred nuggets. No.
So So to make it explicit, right? So one
for Twitch, like PB inspired us to build
our own video server built on top of
FFmpeg, which meant that we were running
our own video streaming software, which
meant that our structural costs for
streaming live video were 10x lower than
our competitors back then. This is in
the days before video ads. So, it was
very hard to run a video company. And
that was the difference. Like that's I
mean, if you're watching live video on
Twitch, like PB was the one who told
Kyle,
>> go do that.
>> Let's not get going for that.
>> Yeah.
>> And and then second, um for Social Cam,
we had this incredible run where we got
about 30 million downloads in three
months. And um PB was basically the one
who told us how to kind of measure our
viral loops so we could optimize it. And
the second time I was wower like he said
something and we were like no that's
wrong PB. And then he's like have you
tried it? And then I was like damn it P.
Like that's when it clicked I was like
you know like
>> he got you like you we haven't tried it
cuz we're dumb.
And then we tried it and and it worked.
I don't want to go into details, but um
it was always very interesting because
like I would always think about the what
I would call the PBPG continuum. Like I
think founders, you know, we tell them
not to shop for advice, but I think they
always shop for advice. You go to
different people for different things. I
always feel like you go to PB to feel
better about your startup. Oh PG PG,
sorry. Yeah. To feel better about like
you you think it's this, but it could be
this, right?
>> And you'd be like, ah, it could be. [__]
yeah.
>> Thanks, PG. I'm great. PG thinks it can
be this. Like maybe it can be right.
Amazing, right? PB would not give you
any of those vibes. Like he'd be real
with you. It's like I remember with
Social Cam, he was like, "I will never
use your product." That was the first
thing he said. I would never use your
product and I've never told my friends
to use your product. And then he he gave
us the thing that made the thing worth
actual money. Um and so PB was always
like, "Give them your hardest problem."
>> Yeah. And so the fact that you're you're
getting to work with him and I would say
honestly the fact that his talents are
going to be used on companies that are a
little further along when you know your
hardest problem is not like oh how do I
get my first user like yeah what did
this investor say and like
>> that's pretty powerful and he was also
known as somewhat of a savant in YC
interviews too which is which is
>> a great interview
>> kind of um most of us who've been around
for a while blur learned like our
tricks. I remember being in the
interview room with PB and like Idis was
like I'm not going to say anything.
Yeah. Just let him let him cook. Let him
just going to watch this. I feel out of
my depth.
>> Yeah. So, no. So, I mean that's in
that's incredible. And then you've got
your old co-founder joining as well.
>> Brian was, you know, the CTO of IEM and
he was the CTO of my second company, Mix
Me Lab. So, we ran a company together
for over a decade.
>> Yes.
>> And, you know, when I started YC, I
introduced him to Patrick Hollison.
>> Okay. Um he became employee 70 at Stripe
>> and he's been a engineer there the whole
time um writing code you know he was
reporting to the CTO of Stripe
>> but wait Dalton you're starting a VC
fund
>> why would you need some like why you
know we all know that you need to get
Microsoft 365
>> Microsoft Teams
>> I've been having to use a lot of
Microsoft Teams recently man it's not
good
>> it's one package and
what why do you need a software
developer Well, I mean, look, we saw
what made YC great, which is at its core
>> is it was a software company created by
a person that loved software
>> and didn't love people. Just kidding.
Didn't love hiring a bunch of people is
a nicer way to say it. Didn't love like
a whole bunch of human process,
>> especially for things that software was
good at.
>> Yeah. So, he would every time there was
a problem at YC, PG would build software
for it. And a lot of the software that
we worked on for all these years can all
be traced back to software that PG
wrote. Yes. And so I think we're heavily
inspired of of of having software at the
very center of things. Okay.
>> Yeah. I think that's such an interesting
point. Like only in hindsight do I
really appreciate how different it was
at YC and how often we asked how can
software help us?
>> Mhm.
>> And like coming out of a startup that
felt like a very natural question. But
talking to other investors I've realized
>> that is one of the most unnatural
questions. Like how can software help
us? Well, we need to hire these young
people so they can scout investors. We
need lawyers. We need
>> a lot of investors build side projects
and they're vibe coding. There's a lot
of vibe coding going on now. Yeah. But
it's core, you know, if what you're
doing is you have you have an email
inbox that comes with warm intros and
it's sending you pitch decks.
>> That's not super softwareentric. Like I
people have been trying to send me pitch
decks and I'm like no thank you
>> because I'm still trained to read YC
applications, right? Like we're all
trained to see the the information in a
very specific format
>> and we're very good at it because all in
the same format when I have to parse
information of a pitch deck, it's really
hard.
>> I think one of the funny things is like
y'all are unpacking so many things where
I feel like this awkward process has
been created around series A is it's not
obvious it makes the series A investors
lives easier either. Well, I think so
much of of the classical series A
investor is relationship based and
reputation based where a lot of what
they do is they have people they trust.
Yep.
>> And they trust the people that they
trust to tell them who to give money to.
And that's kind of the business. Again,
that's not a great, you know, but that's
at the end of the day, that's the that's
the business. It's just sad. Like when I
hear that, it's sad because it's like,
you know, for better or for worse,
especially in a lot of these kind of
shotgun processes, like these people
don't know each other that well. No. And
then it's no big deal. They're just
gonna be on your board and they can fire
you, right? No big deal. Oh, you're
you're you're just meeting a stranger
and maybe they invest and then they fire
you someday. Oh, yeah. That's a I'm
being facicious again, but look, it's
closer to the truth than not.
>> We have a lot of secret stories that we
can never tell that we learned uh at YC
around bad board members.
>> Yeah.
>> And um what was that quote? Not, this is
not my quote, but I remember a founder
being like, "Look, a board member is
either a plus one, a zero, or a minus
one. There's only a handful of plus ones
in the whole world, so try to get a
zero. Go for zero. Try to get a zero
board member." And like, if you can get
a zero, then at least you don't have the
minus ones. That wasn't a joke either
when that when that founder was telling
the story. It's it's so hard cuz I think
that like I don't blame founders for
believing that boards can help. What I
do wish is that I wish there was a way
for a founder to kind of be in one
public board meeting.
>> Yeah. Well, for context, Michael, you're
on the board of Reddit.
>> Yeah. Reddit on the board of Dropbox.
Yeah.
>> And like I just wish I could bring them
into one meeting and then be like, well,
this is like
>> this is how this is like this is like
>> like
>> if this is winning, like what are you
going to have? And if this isn't
winning,
>> what are you going to have? But let's be
clear, everyone's searching for an
oracle. If you present anything in an
Oracle-l like shape, well, the board
will make phone calls for you. We'll
recruit your executives with it. Um, and
it's just so sad when people realize
like there's no Oracle. Like you just
kind of have to figure [__] out.
>> Yeah. They don't have the answers.
>> No.
>> No. Yeah. Yeah. The best Oracle could do
is probably tell you don't quit.
>> Yeah. That's true. That is actually the
best advice is keep going.
>> Yeah. Keep going.
tomorrow will only be as painful or less
painful as today most of the time.
>> Yeah, that's actually really good
advice, you know.
>> Okay, so
you're starting this new fund.
>> Yeah. So, let me just tell you the
actual features. That seems because
we're we're dance around. Let me here's
the features.
>> How is it different?
>> Number one, you're going to apply on our
website. We're creating an application
process just like we had at YC, which
has been the thing I've been, you know,
working on all these years.
>> Yes.
>> And so, you won't need a warm intro. You
don't. It'll just be a website. Anyone
in the world can apply.
>> Put yourself in the mindset. We've seen
founders invest easily a month in
creating a deck, editing a deck,
releasing a deck,
>> and the deck is bad. So, it's like, hey,
I shouldn't say I'm basically often the
first draft of decks we see could use
some improvement. How's that a
>> is that an really bad
>> but and it's not for lack of effort.
Decks are hard.
>> Decks are hard.
>> Decks are hard. And this isn't like the
job which is like making your users
Yeah. better off. Yeah.
>> So, how long should it take to fund an
application?
>> Hour or two. Yeah. Just like you know
for a lot of the YC people that get into
YC, they spend like an hour on the
sometimes less. How many founders have
you talked to? They're like I applied
the day of the deadline 15 minutes
before the deadline came due and then we
got in. Especially for YC that's so
early stage, right? For some extent
there is a little bit of less is more.
>> Yeah. like like there is a little bit of
like if this is early stage and you have
a 50-page deck like what what could you
it's pretty much all down.
Um okay so one there'll be an
application great
>> and so the whole point is to have the
time cost to a founder to be minimal.
>> Yes.
>> So the downside is minimal.
>> You know no one will know you applied.
You spend an hour or two filling out the
application and then the upside is
great, you get money fast. Yeah. Okay.
Okay.
>> Here, here's some of the other features.
Number two, the reason it's called
standard capital
>> is that we're creating a standard series
A term sheet.
>> YC created the safe and it's just on our
website.
>> Whoa. Whoa. So, I don't have to spend
$250,000 with my lawyers.
>> Well, they might still try to bill you.
I'm
>> But what's cool is you can just anyone
in the world can go look at the safe
document.
>> Yeah. and know what the terms are before
you talk to any investors before anyone
applies to Standard Capital. They can
just go read our our term sheet. They
can read our terms.
>> I love that.
>> Isn't that cool? And so you'll know
exactly what the deal is before you
apply instead of it being this opaque
thing where they show you the terms at
the very end of the process after you've
said yes.
>> Well, that's the crazy thing. It's like
they show you like some terms in the
term sheet.
>> Yeah. And then because obviously as a
founder you've had time to go to law
school, they show you this like huge
document that's full of like things that
they've spent a lot of time thinking
about and you haven't
>> and you're at the end of the process. So
what are you going to do? Tell them no.
>> Yeah. Like you have no leverage.
>> You already signed.
>> It's like it's awkward. It's
timeconuming and stressful and and no
one benefits but I guess the lawyers
benefit but other than that like no one
really enjoys that process. So so again
it's called standard capital because
it's the standard series term sheet. The
term sheet will be on the website. You
can see it before you apply.
>> The other thing that's super cool, yes,
is that the standard deal will be for
10% of the company. Yes.
>> U for our lead check.
>> And then the founder as part of the
application
>> will choose their price of how much
money they want to raise from us in
exchange for 10%.
>> So picture a text box where you can type
in six yeah $6 million in exchange for
10% of the company. And that's just part
of the application. You're just filling
it out. you're like, "Okay, six, you
know, seven."
>> How often have we sat down with a
founder and they've said, "Well, I think
I need this much money, but should I ask
for this much money so that they can do
this? And then if I ask for a smaller
amount, then I get multiple people bid
and the and it's this [__] like
>> it's used car sales. It's it's like it's
a used car thing. It's like going to the
market and bartering at the flea
market."
>> Literally,
>> I don't the flea market's easy. You get
the deal done that day.
It's It's true. It's like such a weird
awkward Again, I'm going to use that
word awkward. It's a very awkward
process to do a negotiation like it's
like the olden times.
>> Yes.
>> Because founders always ask me, I don't
know if they ask you this, but they're
like, Dalton, what's the equation to
determine our valuation? And I'm like,
founder, I'm going to
>> It's like I'm telling them Santa Claus
isn't real. Let me be real with you.
There's no equation. Everyone just makes
up numbers. Yep.
>> And you make up a number and they make
up a number. And you keep making up
numbers till somehow there's an
equilibrium and then the deal's done.
>> Yep. And they're shocked. Founders are
shocked to hear that's actually the
science behind this stuff.
>> Well, isn't it, you know, 25 times
forward estimated revenue.
>> Not at an early stage. When you're when
you're a series,
>> whatever. Yeah.
>> Basically public company.
>> Yeah. But no, in the early stage, this
stuff is all made up.
>> So that's I the reason why I think
that's interesting as well is it
reflects so much what we were telling
founders at YC, which is like you set
your own price.
>> Yeah. So this is we're designing
something that is legible to YC founders
cuz at demo day
>> we tell the founders set your cap. This
is my cap. You tell investors the cap
and they're either in or out. Yes.
>> So do you see how this is extremely like
intuitively like I'm I'm designing an
intuitive process. Yes.
>> For YC folks.
>> Yes.
>> Fill out an application standard term
sheet. Yep.
>> Name your own price. Yep.
>> Um we're going to have a quality of
service where it'll tell you how many
days before you get a firm yes or no
from us.
>> That's that's impossible to do.
>> I know. How could you ever?
There's vacations.
>> There's a hot deal you have to chase.
>> Yeah. Because imagine when you were
founder, Michael, imagine if someone
could actually promise you by what date
that you would know they were
confirmatively in or out. Even if they
weren't, even if it's a no, what a gift
to know where you stand versus just
getting stretched out. Oh, I need one
more meeting. Oh, I need to schedule the
partner meeting. Oh, I need to do that.
There's always these extra steps that
get added at the very end. It's just so
weird because like I'm gonna say if
slash when this works and people tell
the stories about how like people are
gonna be like it never this isn't how it
was. Delton you must be exaggerating
like this is not like why how how did
companies even happen if they had to go
through this and sometimes I think like
companies succeed despite this [__]
>> Um
>> yes that's a that's a good way to say
this is a ne this has always been a
necessary evil. Yes,
>> still is kind of a necessary evil, but
there's some hair on the process and you
know this is what founders like to talk
about
>> when they get together is like all their
horror stories. God knows I have some. I
think it's been so interesting because I
think oftent times I'll talk to a VC and
they will say our process is amazing.
>> Y
>> and then I will be like I have talked to
founders who've pitched your firm.
>> Yeah. Um there's one firm was like went
to a partner meeting, full partnership
meeting, no contact for two weeks. They
were thinking about it. Like I know they
weren't thinking about it.
>> But um it's it's almost almost they're
blind. Yeah. And like to lightly defend
investors, I think that there's no
upside for anyone ever telling you to
your face they don't like your process
and that they don't appreciate it. And
so both sides want to preserve
optionality because if you're a founder
you're like I don't like you and I don't
like your process and I'm mad at you.
What I would never advise a founder to
tell an investor that it's all downside
and so I I genuinely think some of these
folks
>> aren't aware of how much psychic damage
they inflict on people.
>> So here's the thing I let's say I'll
give you that enough of these people
were founders.
>> Yep.
>> They know those people know in their
heart. I think the game is the game. And
I'm And again, I'm sure there's people
out there that are like, "Oh, well, the
YC process frustrated me." What I would
say about YC though,
>> yeah,
>> is we always had a date we would tell
you on the website when you applied
where we would send you a no or a yes.
You know, it reminds me of this is a
government aside.
>> When Obama was running for president
in08, one of the things that was said
was that organizing the campaign was
almost a test for how effective he would
be as president. And I think that like
the VC industry has kind of internalized
this idea where it's like how you
organize your fund raise and how you do
these kind of like mind games is like a
test on how good of a founder you're
going to be. And I think that like
that's maybe the idea I want to attack.
Like I don't actually think that's true.
Um, and I think that, you know, and
we've spoken about this at at YC, like
perhaps as the need for capital reduces
as AI becomes more and more powerful, I
think that investors are going to have
to kind of rethink this math cuz like if
the need for capital halves and these
processes stay this awkward, you know, I
I'm working with a company that's doing
$8 million in revenue and they're
profitable and they're like, "Maybe we
should raise a series A, maybe we
shouldn't. Yeah.
>> And you know,
>> especially if it seems high pain,
especially if it seems maybe not likely
to succeed or have negative reputational
damage. Like if you go and raise and you
fund raise fails, the VCs just tell each
other. Like they basically just talk all
day. Yes.
>> About who's raising and what's going on.
Yes.
>> You kind of you actually take damage.
>> You do.
>> If you try to raise and it doesn't work.
>> Well, and we have to advise founders.
It's like you got to go you got to go
away for 6 months. Yeah, you can't do
new [__] and like
>> let's talk about community. So we you
invested in the company.
>> So if you think about why YC really
worked, you go look at the first batch
that Justin was in. Yep. And that Sam
Alman was in. Yep.
>> And it was just like six companies. Yep.
You know, and in with the benefit of
hindsight, those were some of the most
important people in the world.
>> Yep.
>> And those people had a good experience
and they told other people about it.
Yep. And that ultimately the reason
someone wants to be a part of YC is to
opt into being a part of the community
and the other founders. It's not just
the advice from the partners. That's
only a small part of it. It's kind of
like joining the club.
>> Yes.
>> And so the community aspect is the
following. And this is, you know, kind
of bold. Number one,
>> we're not going to take a board seat.
>> Yep.
>> Founders don't want someone who might
fire them. It's weird to to be begging
for money from someone that might fire
you. Yeah. It's a very very awkward
situation again. and you don't really
have time to get to know them well.
Certainly not to pressure test your
relationship.
>> No.
>> And again, there's great board members
out there. I'm just saying it's a it's a
it's a tricky situation.
>> Yes. And instead of just saying, well,
we're not going to take board seats,
whatever, we're actually going to create
these subgroups, kind of like group
office hours at YC, where the founders
will bring them together once a quarter,
so once every three months,
>> and they will present their their
company metrics and their board update
type things and their biggest problems
to each other. And so, it's almost like
this group therapy thing. Um, you're
very familiar with, I mean, a YC if
anyone's a YC lum will be familiar with
group office hours. Believe it or not,
PB invented group office hours. I didn't
know that until you told me that. Um,
and the idea is, look, man, let's be
real. Who do you respect more? Other
people operating companies or trenches?
>> In the trenches, they're actually
dealing with problems in real time. Um,
or people who
>> just kind of repeat stories they hear
from other investors or what have you.
It's it's tricky. And the way I think
about this, man, is Zuck has infinite
resources for Meta. He could get advice
from anyone in the world. Think about
it. He could call someone and get them
on the board of Facebook.
>> Yep. who it is he choose to put on his
board and how to get advice from.
>> Founders,
>> Tony from Door Dash,
>> Yep.
>> Brian from Airbnb, Drew from Dropbox,
>> are all directors of Facebook. And you
know, we we know this from behind the
scenes. That's actually who Zuck has
been consulting with
>> on how to run Facebook as well as the AI
strategy. And who did he bring in to run
the whole Facebook AI strategy?
>> You know, the founder.
>> Yeah. And and these are all YC people.
These are all people that we know.
>> Yes. And so I really think that that is
just such hard proof that ultimately the
best advice you're going to get from as
a founder is from other founders and
from peers that you respect. And so to
the extent standard capital is about
curating this peer group and creating a
structured way for these peers to help
each other.
>> Yeah.
>> I think it's actually just a better
product. If we think of this in terms of
a product,
>> I want that wearing my founder hat. I
want to be a part of that thing and I
don't want a board member. You don't
want a recently graduated MBA who's
picking up their first couple companies
while their VC firm is testing whether
or not they're going to be good or not.
>> And again, those are very nice people
and I like them and I would love them to
>> great people
>> help in some way, but come on.
>> As a founder, that's not who you're
gunning for. Like,
>> yeah, like that's not your dream
situation of who you want advice from.
>> You know, I remember Pedro from Brex
came in to talk to the batch and and he
said a version of this. He said, "I
started accelerating so much more
quickly when I stopped asking investors
to summarize
what they saw other great founders do.
And I started to just ask those founders
directly, what do they do?" Most people
going to YC, they're coming out of
college and they have a peer group
that's like this. And then you just give
them this peer group that's like, "Yeah,
we all want to make the next Google."
>> Yeah.
>> That's different. Like, you know, like
you you just upleveled everyone's
ambition. We've talked about this for
years. Like the same thing doesn't quite
exist for later stage folks.
>> Think about it. We're curating the pure
group of AI builders that have product
market fit like right like that's the
bar to get in to this is you have to
have PMF.
>> Yeah.
>> That's like pretty cool. There's not you
know that's a much
>> Yes.
>> That's a much more rare thing because
think about how many of the really
successful folks we know they don't even
have they have their peer group in the
batch but they're all people are at
different levels of success. Okay, this
is like, wow, these people are all on my
level. I think that's pretty powerful.
And again, I'm super excited that we get
to to to power this for people. You
know, a lot of times when I have
conversations with investors, I think
that they
overvalue the money they're giving
>> and they overvalue their personal
advice. What I like about this is like
you're creating a structure where you're
almost forced to not overvalue those.
Like you're almost forced to create
value not in those areas.
>> Exactly. Yeah, we're happy to give
advice, but this is the the the value
prop is not we we're the best advice
givers. That's not the value prop at
all.
>> No. Right.
>> No. And the value prop isn't like oh
like the company with the biggest check
always win cuz it's [__] never true.
The other thing I feel like we learned
from YC is PG is deeply
anti-zero thinking. Mhm.
>> And so
>> the zero sum way to think about startups
is there's only one good startup that
started every year.
>> Yeah.
>> And that if you don't fund that one
startup, you're bad.
>> Yes.
>> And he had real issues of skepticism
around Y Combinator when he started it
because they were like, "Oh, you're just
going to fund all the bad startups."
>> Great model.
>> This doesn't make this makes this is the
worst idea. Like a lot of people were
like, "You should just give up, man.
You're going to build a baseball team
with all the worst baseball player.
Like you're selecting for bad companies.
Are you nuts? Okay. Seriously. And
again, that really was the the public
perception around it. And his point,
which he's written about a lot,
>> is that there could be more success in
the world and there is not a fixed
amount of successful startups. Yes.
>> And there's not a fixed amount of wealth
and there's not a fixed amount of
growth. And that in fact, these things
feed on each other. And that by funding
lots of startups and funding a lot of
talent.
>> Yes.
>> The net effect would be have more you
know abundance in the world more growth
in the world more successful startups
and he was right.
>> Yes.
>> Cuz it's not like if if PG wouldn't have
funded those early companies they would
have gone on to work without YC. Many of
them wouldn't have like been companies.
>> Twitch
like none. Reddit wouldn't exist in like
there's not an parallel universe where
they didn't do YC and some other
investor funded those companies.
>> Yeah. With this kind of nonzero sum
thinking,
>> we need more software companies.
>> Yes. So, so my thesis is that there's
going to be a lot more big companies
than there ever were. Not one or two a
year. There's going to be more. Yes.
>> My thesis is also I think that a lot of
the VC firms will be fine and that us
funding more great founders. YC didn't
kill the rest of the start because
>> basically I think us funding more great
founders is going to create more
abundance and wealth in the world and
this isn't zero sum thinking and it's
actually disappointing
how zero sum thinking is is pervaded
um a lot of this industry you know
>> especially cuz like you're not you're
not seeing something profound like like
like this kind of positive some thinking
is why tech exists
literally why this stuff works
And so I think it's so awesome.
>> Yes.
>> To be able to to basically get more
people funded and to have them have a
really fast process. And I don't think
that mean I don't think that necessarily
means that every there's going to be
negative side effects to to other folks.
I think it's just going to be great.
>> So this thing's kicking off. Um, I think
the last thing that I loved when you
described this to me is
>> like any software startup, this is the
MVP, but you know, we got to get out
there and figure out what needs to be
built next. And I think that's kind of
the exciting thing is that I remember we
always used to say at YC, we want to try
to earn our 7% every year. And so we
trying to make the product better.
>> Yeah. And we did every year.
>> It was a lot better. I mean, I think we
could objectively. Um, and so I love
that you're kind of bringing your stat
spirit into this.
>> Exactly. Because think because think
about it, we're using the AI tools
themselves to write the code to power
this thing. Yeah.
>> We are intentionally
trying to use AI in every decision we
make. I don't know. We're we're like
treating ourselves as guinea pigs to
kind of create an organization of the
future and how we operate and to be self
similar with our own portfolio
companies.
>> It's how you would do this if you were
operating in the new technology
paradigm. You liked software. Yeah.
Yeah. And you liked founders.
>> Yeah. Which all dovtails back to the
original point which is of all things I
could work on like of the entire
universe. What should I be doing to give
myself advice to give myself office
hours?
>> This is pretty much it. And this in and
same with PB and same with Brian.
>> It's on the nose. So, um, as a last
thing, how do they how do people find
you?
>> standardcap.com.
Uh, probably there'll be a link next to
this video when we talk about it. And
>> there you go.
>> There'll just be an application and
it'll all be documented and super
transparent. Okay. And the first 10
people who apply get 10 million bucks
each for Michael.
>> I like what you did there, Dalton. Great
chat. All right. Appreciate it. Thanks,
Michael.
[Music]